Fortune Magazine is out this morning
with its annual list of America's top
500 companies list has been a measure of
the country's most valuable businesses
since it first came out back in 1955
this year the combined total revenue of
all 500 companies reaches just over 12
trillion
do first on CBS This Morning we're
revealing this year's top companies at
number five is Healthcare Company mck
number four is Exxon Mobile Tech Giant
Apple comes in at number three number
two is Warren Buffett birkshire hathway
and for the F for the fifth straight
year Walmart claims the top spot Alan
Murray is the president of Fortune and
chief content officer of time Inc Allen
good morning good morning all right what
accounts for Walmart being number one
just the sheer volume of stuff they sell
all those stores it's it's really
they're now twice the size in terms of
revenues of the next company on the list
they're really a behemoth now they're
not number one in profits they're not
not number one in market value but in
terms of revenues sheer size they are
number one and they have taken clear aim
at Amazon yeah which is really
interesting Amazon right now is about a
third of the size of Walmart in terms of
uh in terms of revenues but it's but
it's more profit it's I'm sorry it's far
more valued by the market than Walmart
is so Amazon is number two if you look
in terms of what the market thinks the
market value of these companies and big
shout out this morning to Bobby kotak of
Activision Blizzard and El musk of Tesla
who made the list for the first time
because they've made it into the big
ranks of American corporations uh
because of rapid growth gaming company
Activision Activision is a gaming
company it's had something like 400%
growth over the last 5 years so it's
really skyrocketing and of course Tesla
is a is amazing I mean in in the in the
63-year history of the Fortune 500 list
this is the first time there has been a
new car company come on to the list I
mean I we thought with the big three
dominating uh new car companies would
never happen but but El market share
bigger market cap bigger than the other
major major automobile companies it's
it's 383 in terms of revenues but its
market cap is yes uh is high last year
and has surpassed you're right GM and
Ford right last year there were 21
female CEOs of the Fortune 500 how many
this year 32 uh it's still a a a an
awfully small number that means less
than 10% of the CEOs of Fortune 500
companies are women but it's a big
increase it's been stagnant for a number
of years so to see that go up is an
encouraging sign and Apple's number
three on the list but you say they're
moving in the wrong direction uh their
revenues fell last year so they were
number two last year theyve Fallen to
number three still the most profitable
company on the list uh but I think uh
they've they've been struggling a little
bit of late you interviewed 72 CEOs and
you asked them how did the election of
Donald Trump affect your business what
was the response
most of them said no effect uh probably
20% or so said it's been positive but
you know the big runup you've seen in
the stock market is more about
expectations for the future as of right
now they haven't seen a big change Alan
Murray thank you so much